microsoft has acknowledged the xbox
series x release date and price weight
we now know a bit more about destiny 2
beyond light's subclass customization
and if you've been feeling like you need
an extra boost in fall guys then
look no further than big eitis i'm
persia and you reach your state of state
for wednesday september 2nd
[Music]
that's right it's now september and we
still don't have an exact release date
or price for the xbox series x set to
launch in november
fans are eager for more details and
microsoft has finally acknowledged this
xbox uk marketing lead samuel bateman
said on twitter i understand everyone is
excited to know
and people want to plan purchases etc
we'll let you all know when we're ready
bateman was also asked about the launch
lineup since halo infinite was delayed
and it seems once we get the release
date the launch games will become more
clear
so for now we still don't know when the
xbox series x will be released
but make sure you check out generation
next on gamespot for the latest on next
gen news
destiny 2 beyond light will introduce
three new subclasses when it launches in
november
hunters titans and warlocks thanks to a
blog post from bungie we now have more
details on how stasis subclass
customization
will work all three subclasses can be
customized using new aspects and
fragments
aspects are class specific items that
you can mix and match to unlock
different
abilities and fragments can be used by
any class the fragments will give you a
passive perk but
it's gonna penalize your stats in some
way various combinations of
aspects and fragments can be equipped
for different combat strategies such as
the warlock's frost pulse aspect
freezing enemies in range
and then the whisper of refraction
fragment restoring energy
for each frozen enemy you shatter with
stasis being the first new elemental
power added to destiny since the
original trio
of arc solar and void how do you think
this is going to shake up the game
fall guys season 2 is on the way but
another update was teased this morning
that might be the boost you've been
looking for to stack up some crowns
the official fall guys twitter reveals a
new obstacle that will randomly appear
in several levels that can fling you
across the map
and its name is big yiddis we've seen
clips of players getting tossed and
turned by the game's current obstacles
but big eaters will take that one step
further the clip showed a perfect shot
all the way across the finish line but
i'm not so sure it will always be that
successful
fruit also appeared to be getting shot
out of the cannons on the dizzying
heights map in the gif
which may indicate we will be seeing
even more changes but no word yet
on when big edus will be in the game
maybe we'll just have to wait until
season 2 this october
that's all for today feel free to give
me a follow on twitter at persia
underscore exo and make sure you tune in
again tomorrow for your next save state
see ya
you